labrusse pas question de paniquer sur
l'acheminement des vivres pourtant les
trains sont à l'arrêt
je ne suis pas inquiet tout le monde y
était préparé je ne sais pas pourquoi le
gouvernement russe n'en parle que
maintenant et pourquoi il est si choqué
les marchandises ne transite plus par
l'unique ligne ferroviaire qui relie
kaliningrad à moscou et qui passe
notamment par la lituanie états membres
de l'union européenne vignes se fait
blocus et applique de fait les sanctions
décidées par bruxelles contre les
produits russes en réaction à la guerre
en ukraine
bien sûr les sanctions comme les
précédentes laisseront une marque sur
notre région les biens rares ne
disparaîtront probablement pas mais ce
sera sur une courte période et je pense
que le gouvernement trouvera une
solution à cette situation très
rapidement
on ne panique pas en réaction à ces
sanctions le numéro deux du kremlin
après vladimir poutine nikolaï
patrouchev a été envoyé ce mardi en
urgence à kaliningrad un déplacement
sont hautes tensions russo européennes
la russie a menacé venus de représailles
bien sûr la russie réagir à de tels
actes hostiles et leurs conséquences
auront un impact négatif grave sur la
population lituaniens
le kremlin a aussi convoqué
l'ambassadeur de l'union européenne en
russie pour se plaindre officiellement
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer clairement
la position de l'union européenne selon
laquelle il n'y a pas d'interdiction de
transit il n'ya pas de blocus j'ai
appelé la partie russe à rester calme
alors que les sanctions européennes
pleuvent depuis des semaines sur la
russie celle sur kaliningrad affecte
particulièrement le président russe karl
enclave est crucial sur le plan
géopolitique une ville russe au coeur de
l'europe